joined by the shadow home secretary of
vet coupe and are newly appointed of
course congratulations ms cooper thanks
for joining us this morning how
surprised would you be that there were
drug users in the house of commons
it's not something i've ever seen but i
think the speaker of the house of
commons is absolutely right to say this
has to be referred to the metropolitan
police you can't have a um
an institution that's supposed to be law
making and in fact having within it so
much law breaking so i think it's
absolutely right that this is properly
investigated
and what do you think about the
government's suggestion that people who
are convicted of of class a drug crime
should in time potentially lose their
passports um and their driving licenses
well there's we used to have all kinds
of arrangements for um drug treatment
orders for different kinds of responses
through the courts and a lot of that has
just fallen into disuse so we've gone
backwards really over the last 10 years
we've had for example a real loss of
neighborhood policing so that means
there aren't the police there to deal
with that drug dealer on the corner or
that's standing outside the local school
we've also had a 40 drop in drug
treatment in some areas as well so big
drops in drug treatment and it's that
combination i think of the lack of
action on policing pulling that back the
lack of drug treatment the cuts there
and then the lack of coordination
through the cause for some of these
measures is why we have gone badly
backwards so the thing we're looking for
at this strategy today is whether we'll
see action on each of those areas
coordinated approach through the courts
but also the investment in the treatment
that we need get people back into
treatment and in the criminal justice
system so you've actually got the police
to take this action because there's no
point in talking about any of this if
the police just aren't there to actually
identify anyone that's got a problem
we believe that in scotland if somebody
is convicted of a class a drug crime
that they should
probably get a fine from the police
rather than it uh be taken any further
taking the pressure off the prison
system what do you think of that
well i think it's a bit unclear what the
different uh sentencing proposals are
that the government's coming forward
with that's what we're going to have to
look at today at the moment there's a
whole range of different things you can
have but we used to have a system where
the courts we had it was at one point
specialist drug cause we had a system
where the courts could say right we're
gonna say testing or treatment is part
of your sentence is part of what the
court will order and that has just
fallen massively into disuse some of
those used to be used a lot you go back
10 years
and hasn't been much more recently so
that's why some of this it's unclear
whether the government is actually just
trying to reinvent a wheel that frankly
they really should have had rolling 10
years ago and we've had this lost decade
almost so i hope that they're going to
be doing the right thing on some of
these things using the courts in the
right way but also using the police and
public health in the right way if you
don't have that mix of things together
you don't solve the problem
omicron variant are we overreacting no
hospitalizations no deaths it transpires
that we've known about it in the uk
since uh last uh since october
well i really hope that the omicron
variant will turn out not to be a
problem for our vaccine program not to
be a problem
in terms of the the response to the
covet that we've already got but i think
we have to take seriously the scientists
when they say look this is a different
new variant we don't know enough about
it and it is because it is significantly
different we have to slow the spread
before the vaccine the boosters are
fully rolled out and before we've done
the research so get the boosters rolled
out but slow the spread of the virus
that's of the variant that's why i
called for the testing just proper
testing before you get on an airplane
from anywhere in the world so that
you've actually been tested before
you're on a busy flight with a lot of
other people the government waited two
weeks to bring those tests in i think
that was irresponsible but i hope
they're going to get on top of it now
i did put that to the policing minister
and i said don't these tests need to
stay in place until we've seen the back
of this very because otherwise you are
literally closing the door every time
the horse has bolted and he said there
has to be a balance between what we do
and how people manage to go about their
everyday lives
well i think the thing about testing is
that we are getting used to that now
lots of people do lateral flow tests
for kids for school people for different
work for different jobs a lot of the
time so it just seems to me common sense
that you have a lateral flow test before
you get on an airplane that could have
loads and loads of people otherwise by
the time you might discover that you've
got omicron it could be a week later
after all of the delayed testing once
you get back
by which time all of those people you
were on an airplane with all of those
people you were on a train or a tube or
a bus with will then have also spread
right across the country so testing just
seems to be a simple common sense thing
to do that's why i just can't understand
why the government has been so resistant
to it
i'm gathering at number 10 downing
street on the 18th of december
last year um the police commissioner in
london crested dick says that she has
not been told about it you're the shadow
home secretary why have you not raised
it with her
well i understood this had been raised
with her and i think to be honest she
really should have noticed it in the
newspapers because there's been a lot of
reporting on it i think the government
is um has been disgraceful in the way
they're responding to this they keep
saying oh well we don't recognize
reports oh well the rules were followed
how can the rules have been followed if
they had a party on december the 18th
when they were telling everybody else to
cancel their parties when they were
telling everybody else to cancel
christmas and it is classic one rule for
them another for everyone else they
cannot do this especially in a public
health pandemic they have to sustain
trust in the things that they ask
everybody else to do and not just think
they can rip up the rules for themselves
and that means they also have to be
honest about what they've done rather
than this shenanigans trying to pretend
all nothing happened but never quite
saying it and everybody knows there's
something dodgy going on
but back to my point if the
most important
police officer in the country says she
has not been told about it and you are
an incredibly important politician in
the house of commons uh the leader when
it comes to um the home office and
policing for your party are you going to
lift the phone up to it today and say
okay i'm raising it with you now
well we may need to follow up on this
but i just don't understand that
response because you know i understand
that uh other mps have raised it
directly with her and and also that it
has been in the newspapers repeatedly so
i just simply don't understand this idea
of them not being aware of it now they
certainly obviously not been told about
it by the government because the
government seems to be just trying to
hide the fact that this happened i think
it's just just come back to
the
the core question which is they have to
just stick with the rules that they make
for everyone else they have to respect
them and they have to respect everybody
else across the country who they are
asking to make sacrifices and it's that
failure to do so it's not just about one
party it's about the impact it has on
trust right across the country and at
the moment actually we cannot trust this
prime minister we cannot trust this
government on anything like this but
just let me press that point if i may
because she was on the radio on friday
and she did say to my old mate nick
ferrari um i have not had any
communication about this personally it's
going to take you two seconds to lift
the phone to her she's going to take
your call isn't she
well i want you to find out what's
happened because my understanding is
that this has actually been raised with
her and she has been sent um of
questions about this by other mps by
other london mps
so i will look into what's happened here
okay good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed for joining us